there's a lot better than their record
shows but you're dealing with this team
lost 12 two offensive rebounds
back-to-back tryst you don't want to
give this team vote for shot baby look
good out of his hand good 1074 here
Nelson takes up the through a holiday
good setup that's your past each one
more free Davis for the lead off at the
time into the past by Jameer knows
through his career Purdue been able to
shoot the ball better and the thing to
do the things that takes us out on the
court
so it just been great watching them grow
over the years and consistently
consistently be a corner three yes it's
been that good he had a triple beam
Chicago only two tries beyond the arc
beam stops as well feeds one more easy
set up and we were just talking about it
hats engineering that's it manny leads
the team in blocks that's the problem
takeaway Anthony Davis coming up with
Dante Cunningham and points off the
takeaway in give up a big lead 19 in
that game
pelicans have to overcome a 14
here's a block Anthony Davis Oladipo out
of the break 8680 holiday leaves it off
ad triple yes then you down here how
good is it for Anthony Davis three a
free from the on the line one man down
they figured it out they came up with
the rebound Holliday has Anthony Davis
hammers at home and made up a
three-point game 9188 with one Anthony
Davis and the pelicans are outscored the
Pacers here in the third by 15 with
plays like that on the shoulders of
Davis for his second block of the game
we got that up quick
Darius Miller fills it up teaching under
the screens
belongs to the Pels got to make them pay
holiday hit it inside he will ap gets it
five-point lead matches the largest of
the game for the Pels before 20 to play
he wanted it finally gets it against
Thaddeus Young
five of the shot clock
got it tells my three ad all day and
night nothing no indeed this is a post
up and this is where his game has grown
there were times when he would have
taken that still off-balance who see him
get his balance and his rhythm and just
raise up here you go Oladipo no fouls he
walked again and got away with it
it'll be Turner blocked away by the guy
who's done it all tonight Anthony Davis
that'll do it